So now let's look at the whole pipeline of how we would go for
an image, to extract an edge image out of it.
Again an edge image would be basically showcasing where most of
the contrast changes are in an image and
best represents the changes in the spatial x and y of an image like this.
As we noticed before first thing we want to do is we want to suppress noise.
You want to run some sort of a smoothing operation, a blur kernel
using a Gaussian kernel to be able to get rid of some of the information because
as we noticed, the gradient image calculation is really sensitive to noise.
Of course, next step is we compute the gradient image after the image has been
smoothed out a little bit.
And you would get something like this where all of the intensity information,
basically where the gradient is the largest, is shown by the white lines here.
And this is a gradient magnitude image.
Third step is we apply some sort of edge enhancement,
which basically means is that we will filter this image for contrast.
Bring out the most value of where the gradients are much,
much more higher than anything else.
Otherwise, if you notice, this image is basically just black and
white, with lot less white.
We want to bring out the white information here to actually have
more local information around the whites.
because we don't want to lose any information because we've just linearly
looked at the space between zero to 255.
So we want to kind of enhance this data structure,
which is basically an intermediate one from here to there so
we can actually start looking for edges more carefully.
Next thing we want to do is we want to start localizing edges.
Which basically means is we need to determine which local maximum from
any filter output is actually referring to edges as opposed to noise.
So in essence we want to kind of look for
filter responses, and start attracting it various types of ways.
A differential that let's us get rid of noise and pay attention to edges.
Many different methods for this exist.
I recommend you to look at the text for this.
I'll just showcase one of them in a bit.
Finally, the last step is, we want to threshold information after we've done all
of this, and also sometimes do something which is referred to as thinning,
which is a morphological operator on images that basically let's you
combine pixels and close bytes into a much more thinner representation.
because in essence we're looking for
a fine resolution image where the edges are likely to be in this, image.
The output of course is a image like this, which looks similar but
if you notice now it's mostly just one pixels of lines everywhere.
It's very hard to see because again the way it's represented here,
in black and white.
But you'll see many examples of this as you do this work yourself.
But, this is one of the best ways to look for an edge image.